intentemos resolver este problema dice
el bloque inicial que se muestra abajo
tiene dos unidades de longitud es decir
este este que es mi bloque base mi
bloque inicial tiene dos unidades
longitud de aquí acá hay dos unidades y
por lo tanto justo la mitad hay una y
aquí habría media que se yo use las
herramientas de la derecha es decir está
de aquí a la derecha tengo a una dos
tres herramientas para convertir el
bloque inicial
en este bloque lo vamos a convertir en
dos bloques objetivos que tienen el
primero uno y un cuarto unidades de
longitud es decir queremos llegar a este
bloque objetivo que tiene una unidad con
un cuarto de longitud ok y la otra
tienen tres octavos unidades de longitud
que es este de aquí es de aquí tiene
tres octavos de unidades de longitud tu
progreso se verá reflejado en el cambio
de longitud del bloque de prueba
y entonces vamos a tener aquí dos
bloques de prueba el bloque de prueba
uno lo que prueba dos lo que quiero
hacer es llevar a estos bloques de
prueba a que se conviertan en el bloque
objetivo tanto en el bloque objetivo uno
que por cierto sabemos que tiene una
unidad un cuarto de longitud y por otra
parte el bloque objetivo 2 que tiene
tres octavos unidades de longitud
ahora para eso quiero que te des cuenta
que lo que necesitamos es que todo tenga
el mismo denominador aquí si te das
cuenta tenemos un denominador de 4 y
aquí un denominador de 8 y necesito el
mismo denominador porque este bloque
inicial lo vamos a partir en una cierta
cantidad de pedazos y esa cierta
cantidad de pedazos la vamos a repetir
las veces que sea necesario para llegar
a esta longitud
bien pues hagámoslo si veo mi
denominador de 4 y mi denominador de 8
el denominador en común es pues
precisamente 88 múltiplos de 8 y es
múltiplo de 4 por lo tanto voy a dividir
a este bloque que tengo aquí en
8 partes iguales y para eso quiero que
te des cuenta que si yo lo corto aquí
una vez entonces aquí tengo una unidad
de aquí acá y de que acá tengo otra
unidad por lo tanto lo que necesito es
cortar a este bloque en octavos y lo
acabo de partir una vez por lo tanto
necesito partirlo otra vez aquí tengo
representado un tercio del bloque de dos
unidades pero yo lo que quiero son
octavos octavos de bloque por lo tanto
lo voy a partir otra vez aquí tengo
cuartos un cuarto dos cuartos tres
cuartos cuatro cuartos ok
aquí tengo cinco piezas seis piezas
siete piezas y ocho piezas justo en este
momento quiero que te des cuenta que
aquí tengo representado un cuarto de una
unidad aquí tengo un cuarto de una
unidad o si nosotros lo pegamos ocho
veces
si lo pegamos ocho veces tendremos dos
unidades pero recuerda atrás lo que
vamos no es
un bloque que quepa ocho veces en dos
unidades sino lo que necesitamos es un
bloque que quepa 16 veces en dos
unidades o de otra manera ocho veces en
una unidad una forma en la cual puedes
visualizar esto es que si te das cuenta
aquí necesitaríamos tres bloques para
llegar al bloque objetivo 2 y si ponemos
tres de estos nos pasamos por lo tanto
necesito todavía partir un poco más a
estas dos unidades cuántas veces más
bueno pues en esta parte de los de hecho
16 veces necesito un bloque que sea 16
veces lo que quepa en dos unidades este
bloque de aquí caben 16 veces en dos
unidades o dicho otra manera cabe ocho
veces en dos unidades que es justo lo
que queríamos porque fíjate bien si
nosotros pensamos en el bloque 2
necesitamos 3 octavos 3 de estos bloques
para lograr el objetivo 2 entonces vamos
a verlo
23 si yo le pongo tres veces en este
bloque que es lo que prueba justo lo
multiplicó por tres llegó al bloque
objetivo 2 que es justo lo que quería
ahora nos falta el bloque objetivo 1 y
para eso aquí tengo un octavo tengo
solamente un octavo de un entero y yo lo
que quiero llegar es a un entero un
cuarto bueno pues que te parece si
pasamos esto a octavos que es mi
denominador común un entero un cuarto es
lo mismo que un 88 más 210 octavos diez
octavos porque aquí tengo cuatro por uno
más uno es cinco cuartos y cinco cuartos
es lo mismo que diez octavos entonces ya
que tengo ese bloque lo voy a
multiplicar por diez ok
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve y diez o espera espera me
pase por una vez diez para llegar justo
al bloque objetivo uno que es este de
aquí y ver si ya tengo mi bloque de
prueba 1
objetivo 1 mi bloque de prueba 2 y lo
que objetivo 2 muy bien distribuidos
es hora de comprobar respuesta y ya lo
logramos
hasta la próxima